hey you this is pressed Hall Locker and
you're watching mind your decisions you
are playing a chess match against a
skilled opponent for a given game there
is a 75% chance the game will end in a
draw all the games that do not end in a
draw there is a two-thirds chance you
will win and a one-third chance you will
lose the first player to win two games
in a row is declared the winner of the
chess match what is the probability you
will win the chess match
I think Mika from Sweden for suggesting
this problem can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for a solution
[Music]
you
for a given game there is a 75% or three
and four chance the game will end in a
draw what's the chance of all games that
it will end in a win or a loss for you
well notice there's a one minus 3/4
which equals 1/4 chance that any
particular game will not end in a draw
you win
2/3 of these games which is 1/4 times
2/3 which equals 1/6 of all games
similarly you lose the other 1/3 of such
games which is 1/4 times 1/3 which
equals 1/12 of all games so the
probability a particular game ends in a
draw is 3 over 4 the probability a
particular game ends in a win for you is
1 over 6 and the probability a
particular game ends at a loss is 1 over
12 now how can we solve for the chance
that you win this entire chess match
we'll set up three different variables
let's write D to equal the probability
you eventually win the match given that
the previous game was a draw
we'll write W to equal the probability
you ultimately will win the match given
the previous game was a win and write L
to equal the probability you'll
ultimately win the match given the
previous game was a loss on the very
first game there is no previous game so
we can model this as if the previous
game was a draw game 0 is equal to a
draw we therefore want to solve for D
because we want to solve for your
probability of winning from the very
beginning now if the previous game was a
draw there are three things that could
happen the game could end in a draw with
a 3/4 chance and then your chance to win
is still D because then the previous
game will still be a draw now the game
could end in a win with a 1/6 chance and
then your chance to ultimately win the
tournament will be W finally the game
could
in a loss with the 112 chance and then
your chance to win will be L so we can
write this in a single equation D is
equal to 3/4 times D plus 1/6 times W
plus 1/12 times L so we figured out one
equation for D and we can do similar
thing for WL now to figure out the
equation for W consider if the previous
game was win again there are three
possible things that could happen the
game could end in a draw with a 3/4
chance and then your chance to
ultimately when the match will be d the
game could end in a win with a 1/6
chance in that case you've won two games
in a row because the previous game was a
win and the current game is win in this
case you win for sure this will be one
the game could also end in a loss with a
1/12 chance and then your chance to
ultimately win will be L so we can write
the equation for W as follows it equals
3/4 times D plus 1/6 times 1 plus 1/12
times L so we now can figure out one
more equation for L this will be found
if the previous game was a loss again
there are three things that could happen
the game could end in a draw with 3/4
chance and then your chance to win is d
the game could end in a win with the 1/6
chance and then your chance to win is W
finally the game could end in a loss
with a 1/12 chance in this case you will
lose for sure because you've lost the
previous game and you've lost the
current game so you've lost two games in
a row which means the other player has
won two games in a row so your chance to
win this will be zero so the equation
for L is that L is equal to 3/4 times Z
plus 1/6 times W plus 1/12 times 0 so we
now have three different equations in
three variables we have a linear system
of three equations and three variables
so we can solve for each variable it's a
somewhat tedious calculation so you
use an algebraic solver if you're
curious I provided these steps in detail
in my blog post ultimately we get the
probability when the match is equal to
the value for D which is equal to 26
over 33 which is approximately 78 point
eight percent your odds are pretty good
you have about a seventy eight point
eight percent chance of winning two
games in a row and winning this chess
match did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video these math videos
which can be watched for free inspire
and build confidence for people around
the world and they already have over 800
million views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can map
the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the news
videos watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos email me a puzzle or
math topic presh and mind your decisions
calm if you so choose you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support